in china im zdf-sommerinterview beklagt
bundespräsident steinmeier das land
verstoße in hongkong gegen
internationale vereinbarungen stichwahl
in polen ein gespaltenes land sucht
einen präsidenten noch ist offen wer das
rennen macht und corona in den usa
infektionszahlen auf rekordniveau und
widerstand gegen jumps plan ausländische
studenten auszuweisen
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg sonntag der zwölfte juli
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch rudi cerne für den sport hallo
guten abend deutschland sei mit seiner
kritik an china viel zu zurückhaltend
das moniert nicht nur die opposition
umso überraschender heute die scharfen
worte des bundespräsidenten richtung
peking im zdf sommerinterview in potsdam
äußerte sich frank walter steinmeier
auch zu den lehren aus der korona krise
hat tritt er wieder meyer auch der
bundespräsident war in den letzten
monaten zum home office verdammt
verbrachte mehr zeit zu hause und nutzte
sie wie andere auch äußerst effektiv wie
er zu beginn des berlin direkt
interviews verriet ich habe in der tat
ob sie es glauben oder nicht
zwei tage lang drei tage lang in seinen
keller aufgeräumt habe bei der
gelegenheit man halt das rennrad
wiederentdeckt große reisen
staatsbesuche treffen mit bürgern all
das war nicht möglich stattdessen
telefonierte er fiel zum beispiel mit
pflegekräften oder kassiererinnen
steinmeier mahnt applaus alleine reiche
für diese berufsgruppen nicht
wir müssen das jetzt auch einlösen diese
wertschätzung an der gesellschaft wie
der unseren drückt sich eben
wertschätzung auch in bezahlung aus und
das wird sich jetzt zeigen ob wir diese
bereitschaft tatsächlich haben
mahnende worte auch an die abgeordneten
des bundestages endlich eine
wahlrechtsreform auf den weg zu bringen
dies sei eine kernfrage der demokratie
man muss sich jetzt aufeinander
zubewegen und am ende muss der bundestag
eine entscheidung treffen das kann ihm
niemand ersparen und dann noch ein
appell an china das völkerrechtswidrige
vorgehen in hongkong zu beenden es kommt
ja nicht allzu oft vor dass deutschland
plus der gesamten europäischen union
plus aller industriestaaten g-7 seine
tiefgreifende sorge gegenüber den
entwicklungen dort zum ausdruck bringt
worauf es ankommt ist dass wir china
jetzt klar machen das ist nicht ein
zustand aktuelle empörung sondern wenn
es dabei bleibt dann wird es eine
nachhaltige negative veränderung zu den
europäischen zu den westlichen staaten
geben deshalb hofft der ehemalige
außenminister das ist doch noch eine
umkehr im chinesischen denken geben wird
das ganze sommerinterview mit dem
bundespräsidenten sehen sie direkt nach
uns ein schlechter kompromiss ist besser
als keiner so bewertet außenminister maß
die einigung im un sicherheitsrat
danach gehen die internationalen
hilfslieferungen für syrien jetzt doch
weiter aber in eingeschränkter form
künftig werden lebensmittel und
medikamente nur noch über einen
grenzübergang geliefert statt wie bisher
über 2 damit hat sich russland
durchgesetzt im nordwesten syriens sind
2,8 millionen menschen aus hilfsgüter
angewiesen
die polen entscheiden heute über die
zukunft ihres landes noch zwei stunden
läuft die stichwahl ums präsidentenamt
entweder der regierungstreuen national
konservative präsident du da bleibt im
amt oder es gewinnt sein herausforderer
der warschauer bürgermeister laskowski
er kämpft für ein liberales und europa
freundliches polen den letzten umfragen
zufolge liegen beide nahezu gleichauf
natalie steger in warschau warum ist
diese wahl so wichtig für polen und ja
auch für europa die wahl bedeutet
tatsächlich sehr viel es bedeutet vor
allem wie geht es mit polen diesem land
die nächsten drei jahre weiter denn die
nächsten parlamentswahlen
die sind erst 2023 und die
nationalkonservativen pis die regiert
hier bislang durch mit absoluter
mehrheit aber der präsident in polen ist
durchaus mächtig er hat ein vetorecht
bei gesetzen und kann die damit auf eis
legen sprich er kann sie verhindern du
da hat das nicht getan der national
konservative amtsinhaber er hat auch
umstrittene gesetze durchgewunken und
das wäre dann ein weiter so mit dem
peace kurs in polen jazz kowski der
oppositionskandidat hat angekündigt er
würde nicht mehr alles blind links
unterschreibt was bedeuten würde dass
die pis bei ihrem umbau des landes des
polens ziemlich ausgebremst wäre ja und
für europa würde das bedeuten wenn du
der präsident bleibt dann sind konflikte
mit polen für brüssel weiterhin
vorprogrammiert mit dem
oppositionskandidaten an der
staatsspitze würde es für brüssel
etwas leichter danke für diese
einschätzung aus warschau natalie steger
war das und jetzt der blick auf die
korona zahlen in deutschland da ist die
lage stabil im schnitt der vergangenen
sieben tage haben sich täglich 360
menschen neu mit dem virus angesteckt
genauso viele wie gestern komplett
anderes bild in den usa dort infizieren
sich immer schneller immer mehr menschen
aktueller höchstwert mehr als 66.000
neuinfektionen an einem tag wegen der
pandemie plant die regierung
ausländische studenten auszuweisen
deren unis im kommenden semester nur
online kurse anbieten
auch 9200 deutscher wären betroffen sie
bitten nun die bundesregierung um hilfe
rt wissen berichtet donald verträgt
maske als er verwundete soldaten im
krankenhaus besuchte ein hauch von
einsicht dass die korona gefahr
dramatisch wächst trotzdem will dass die
universitäten wieder öffnen die
einwanderungsbehörde macht nun allen
internationalen studenten zur auflage
dass sie persönlich an seminaren
teilnehmen
sonst verlieren sie ihr aufenthaltsrecht
hochschulen wie herbert wollten nur
online kurse anbieten aber dann dürften
ausländische studierende 400.000
insgesamt nicht weiterstudieren
maximilian klein wäre einer von ihnen
gemeinsam mit kommilitonen von herbert
bittet er in einem brief die deutsche
regierung um hilfe
sie befürchten weitreichende finanzielle
und psychische belastungen
es sei eine fremdenfeindliche
einwanderungspolitik und einen angriff
auf den internationalen akademischen
austausch da haben ganz viele
studierende einen enormen aufwand
betrieben auch viel risiko auf sich
genommen um an diesen unis auch
studieren zu können
teilweise den lebensmittelpunkt in
deutschland aufgegeben teilweise in
begleitung von angehörigen unverschuldet
jetzt ausgewiesen zu werden ist
natürlich ungerecht und willkürlich
nach zdf informationen will die
bundesregierung die studenten nach
möglichkeit unterstützen die situation
in gesprächen thematisieren klarere
worte kommen aus dem bundestag
der amerikanische präsident tom betreibt
die nahezu infantile weise eine corona
politik in der das
wirklichkeit sein soll was er sich
wünscht und er ignoriert die fakten der
krise auf den buchrücken der studenten
wird hier ein streit ausgetragen
die universitäten befürchten
milliardenverluste ohne studierende aus
dem ausland sie klagen nun gemeinsam mit
bundesstaaten gegen die vorgaben sie
wollen den präsidenten klar machen dass
ein normalbetrieb in corona zeiten zu
gefährlich ist
israel hat eine zweite corona welle
bereits voll erwischt wegen der enormen
wirtschaftlichen folgen kündigte
ministerpräsident netanjahu heute
finanzielle soforthilfen an
gestern abend noch demonstrierten
tausende gegen seine corona politik
darunter auch viele selbstständige und
kleinunternehmer
die arbeitslosenquote liegt mittlerweile
über 20 prozent neuinfektionen stiegen
zuletzt auf immer neue rekordwerte so
dass wieder neue beschränkungen verhängt
wurden wie schon am vergangenen
wochenende haben auch heute wieder
motorradfahrer gegen mögliche
fahrverbote demonstriert in leipzig
versammelten sich mehr als 16.000 biker
ursprünglich waren nur 600 angemeldet
sie protestierten gegen einen vorstoß
des bundesrats der fahrverbote an sonn
und feiertagen ermöglichen will
damit soll der motorradlärm reduziert
werden motorenlärm das passende
stichwort für dich und genau auf vier
rädern
doppelerfolg für die beiden mercedes
silberpfeile die in dieser saison in
schwarzfahren lewis hamilton gewinnt den
großen preis der steiermark in spielberg
vor teamkollege valtteri bottas ferrari
erlebt einen totalschaden auf ganzer
linie für ferrari fans ein bild des
grauens charles' klären schießt
sebastian vettel schon in der dritten
kurve ins aus und muss anschließend
selbst sein auto abstellen
ja ich habe keinen platz gehabt irgendwo
anders hin zu fahren ich habe nämlich
auch aus allem rausgehalten der dritte
kurve hinein drei autos in der ecke geht
nicht ich weiß nicht welche lücke charts
dann gesehen habe sei es war mein fehler
sebastian hat nichts falsch gemacht es
war nicht sein fehler
weltmeister lewis hamilton dominiert
beim ersten grandprix der steiermark und
gewinnt vor seinem teamkollegen valtteri
bottas der weiterhin
gesamtwertung anführt skurril die
siegerehrung in corona zeiten das letzte
spiel der saison in den deutschen profi
fußball ligen war noch mal ein
dramatisches in der relegation rettet
der erste fc nürnberg beim fc ingolstadt
den klassenerhalt zur zweiten liga den
entscheidenden treffer erzielte fabian
schleusener in der nachspielzeit
wohin mit all diesen gefühlen den nicht
mehr erhofften glücks ausbrüchen und dem
totalen frust ingolstadt fühlt sich um
den aufstieg betrogen denn sie hatten
mit dem 13 0 nach gut einer stunde doch
das wunder vollbracht den rückstand aus
dem hinspiel aufgeholt und die fünf
minuten nachspielzeit waren auch schon
vorbei als nürnberg noch ein letztes mal
den ball hoch nach vorne schlug und
schleuser ihn irgendwie ins tor
spitzelte nur deswegen bleibt ingolstadt
in der dritten und nürnberg mit torwart
martin ja in der zweiten liga der kann
die tränen nicht zurückhalten es waren
einfach zu viele gefühle für ein
fußballspiel und das wars vom sport
vielen dank
wettermäßig beginnt die woche gar nicht
schlecht nach einem meist sonnigen start
gibt es später ein paar wolken aber es
bleibt trocken an der küste weht ein
lebhafter westwind die temperatur steigt
auf werte von 18 bis 28 grad mal jetzt
slomka begrüßt sie um viertel vor zehn
im heute-journal wir bedanken uns ganz
herzlich für ihr interesse wünschen
ihnen noch einen entspannten
sonntagabend und sagen tschüss hier ist
jetzt zeit fürs zdf sommerinterview mit
dem bundespräsidenten und mit theo koll